hey so welcome back for those that are
just tuning in I'm Jesse and I'm here at
the Wolfram tech conference 2017
talking in developers and attendees kind
of seeing what they're doing with our
you know technology and see what kind of
interesting ways they're they're using
it in so right now I'm here with
Devendra who's going to talk a little
bit about what he does here at the
company and kind of over some new
improvements to the language so hello
Jesse and everyone I'm Devendra I work
in the kernel development group at
Wolfram I'm very focused on calculus
I love calculus I have always done
calculus in my life and I think calculus
is probably the most attractive part of
the social language at least for someone
like me and it's been there forever and
people use it students professors
researchers hobbies the well prize
winners who knows who use calculus and
my job is to try and make it better then
what it which is pretty difficult and
then to try and make it more useable
more friendly more attractive to people
who are trying to learn calculus at any
level so that's my job over here so what
are some of the latest improvements to
calculus which has been around since the
introduction of the Wolfram language and
also calculus that soap has been around
for centuries so what are some of the
latest improvements in 11.2 that were
not in say 11.1 right so 11.2 is the
place where we decided that we really
wanted to improve what are called limits
in calculus so limits are a part of
calculus and they have been there in the
world from languages in 1988 version 1
but what we've gone and done is to
completely reemployment limits we
implemented so called multivariate
limits we have a lot of documentation
lot of benchmarking with millions of
examples and what we have now is perhaps
the most usable system for limits in
so that's 11.2 and moving forward we're
trying to make things even more
available to people by doing better
documentation cause what sir perhaps we
should just look at something which
concretely show what we have done a last
couple of versions
okay so one particular theme that we've
been working on is the so called nth
derivative of a function so if you look
at the function sine X then the first
derivative is cosine the second one
negative sign etc and now what you got
is the nth derivative of this function
just a nice compact formula and you can
do all kind of things with it such so
very generalized kind of calculus far
beyond college calculus and just a week
ago we learned that professor Sir
Michael berry who's a very famous famous
physicist was important chaos I had
published a paper showing that these in
there it was a real like they're like
waves okay so they they become they like
the higher harmonics from music which
capture finer and finer tones and that's
what is singing oh you're seeing that
the high derivatives are somewhat like
sines and cosines they capture all the
fine aspects of a function so in very
reserved a profound an important
improvement in system um so you
mentioned that there were dramatic
improvements for limiting behavior
functions as well can you explain a
little bit about what sort of improved
sure so we have been having limits for
ever like I said but my colleague Adam
stress monkey decided that he really
wanted to do everything from ground up
so he's implemented a very very
important algorithm which essentially
solves pretty complicated limits we have
checked it against every textbook every
published paper as far as possible but
the key thing now is that we can do
these so-called multivariate limits so
you have a function of two variables
because he's right over here
look at the plot something strange is
happening you at the origin depending on
which way you approach the origin you
get different answers so if you approach
it along the line y equal to zero you
get one if you put a long line x equals
zero you get negative five so the limit
seems not to exist and we actually can
now show that this limit does not exist
that's a hard problem if you could do
solve this on your own by hand but kind
of certifying the limit does not exist
requires authority and my colleague Adam
is really a thority on limits now he's a
bronze medalist and he's actually
checked with all your examples and what
now have his world-class multivariate
limit functionality backed by every
single this this is really incredible
because when I was going through my
calculus courses I mean most calculus
sequences they learned l'hopital's rule
which you know it doesn't really work
for anything that's so having something
that evaluates limits where you don't
have to go through that you know kind of
tedious college brothers ruling on
l'hopital's rule have been there forever
actually l'hopital discovered rule but
it's not known that actually look at all
paid Bernoulli to write a textbook so
but it is called l'hopital's rule but
even pay someone you get the courage so
no propose really good run again because
he's really burn these row no but
l'hopital's rule had a problem the
problem is that l'hopital's rule can go
on forever so in the 1960s there there
were computer draw systems at MIT etc
but they would try l'hopital's rule
let's say six times or seven time they
know to stop so today we don't we use
l'hopital's rule but we also go step
beyond that use something called the
gern's algorithm and so we have a
surefire way of catching every limit and
just this week
adam is working through another thousand
examples checking
and they'll be all correct so believe me
they put a heart into this it's gonna be
really great
it sounds like y'all thought of just
about everything a student would need
can you discuss a little bit more about
the sort of education initiatives that
you're hoping to sort of do implement
would be as these new features and
calculus sure so I think if calculus is
close to anything then it's close to
education and forever people have been
using Mathematica to do calculus and we
have had good document if we got good
from alpha which is a very nice place to
do calculus but what we'd like to do is
to make what we have available in the
simplest possible form so the reference
base for D and limit of the functions
are now being improved dramatically
they have examples from standard
textbooks and they have animations that
govern you see over here and typically
these pages are now like a textbook so
you don't need to really go to a
textbook on the subject
go to our reference pages you learn it
all going step beyond even I taught for
a long time and I'm a teacher at heart
and I I'm very disciplined and I like to
get up at 5:30 4:00 in the morning that
kind of thing you know so I think that
teaching is very important and we are
trying to use all that we have to give
our very own
Veon calculus we might even think of
doing a small course in the near future
where people can come and learn calculus
in a very nice geometrical way in a very
friendly setting but the Wolfram
language Imana
so that's our dream our dream is to make
calculus did you create an even better
order study that really is all that
sounds incredible I wish I had these
features when I was you know a freshman
taking my count
are there so aside from these sort of
improved algorithms and what do you hope
to do for a living when it rolls out ah
that's a good question well we don't
quite know you know we work as a
research team so we have a plan and that
then might collapse and but for 11.3 we
actually have got a pretty good plan the
plan is that you know at the moment
there are two kind of computation people
have symbolic computation so you have a
nice formula which gives you all the
information you have like you know D or
limit or whatever and then your symbolic
you could numeric computation so
numerical computation means that you do
things approximately with numbers and
that's very popular what we want to do
is to kind of go somewhere between those
two be one to reading the best of
Symbolics and numerix and do kind of
approximate symbolic solutions so that's
a very powerful theme and that's our
theme for version 11.3 we can look at
differential equations integral etcetera
from an approximate symbolic point of
view so everything we've done so far is
a build up to eleven point three where
you see some dramatic functionality for
solving differential equations in a new
way not symbolic not numeric but
approximate symbolic or what we call
asymptotic awesome well thank you for
talking with me about this this is
really really cool stuff out of your
busy schedule here yes I do have three
dogs on the one tomorrow on Thursday a
joint talk with Adam and then to mourn
Friday so we're hoping to give off your
point we put a lot of work this is a one
time he can meet people and tell them
so thank you very much between the
Draper yeah well I hope all your talks
go well that's a lot for one conference
so good luck thank you